in the opening scene we are introduced
to the protagonist Anita needy who is
placed in a mental Asylum it appears
that she is a dangerous patient which
becomes even more evident when she
attacks a nurse without any reason Anita
is tossed into a dark cell as punishment
and during her time there she recounts
all the events of her past life the
story then shifts to a flashback taking
us to Devil's Kettle a small town named
after a mysterious waterfall for some
reason the water flows into a deep hole
and never comes out no one knows where
it goes and even scientists are baffled
by this phenomenon Anita then tells us
about her best friend Jennifer a popular
and attractive cheerleader at their
college unlike herself despite having
very little things in common the two
enjoy each other's company Anita also
has a boyfriend named chip but she holds
a stronger affection for her best friend
than for her romantic partner sorry Jeff
on a particular evening Jennifer invites
Anita to a local dive bar where an indie
rock band named shoulder is going to
perform upon their arrival Jennifer gets
drawn to the lead performer Nicholas so
she approaches him the two then shot for
a while and Jennifer is sent to get some
drinks while she is away Nicholas
approaches his bandmates and discusses
Jennifer's virginity saying she will be
perfect for their project their indie
rock concept album Anita who overhears
their conversation feels weird and later
shares it with her best friend however
Jennifer doesn't pay much attention to
it soon after the band starts their
performance and everyone begins to enjoy
themselves however a sudden electrical
short circuit causes a fire that rapidly
spreads throughout the bar chaos ensues
as people scramble to save their lives
amidst the commotion the two friends
managed to escape through a bathroom
window surprisingly the band members are
already outside acting in a relaxed
manner as if nothing happened they talk
for a while and out of the blue Nicholas
asks Jennifer to join them the whole
thing creeps Anita out but Jennifer
agrees without any hesitation she even
ignores her best friend and gets into
the guy's van after they drive away
Anita returns home and immediately
contact her boyfriend sharing all the
details of the incident with him in the
middle of their conversation Anita is
startled by the sound of the doorbell
intensifying her fear she slowly
proceeds downstairs and opens the door
but discovers nobody outside with a
sense of unease she returns to a room
but then hears noises coming from the
kitchen Anita goes to investigate the
source only to find Jennifer completely
covered in blood to make matters more
creepy she lets out an evil smirk
Jennifer then opens the fridge and
starts to devour raw chicken just then
she screams at the top of her lungs and
vomits a trail of dark fluid it appears
as if she has been possessed by some
sort of devilry either that or she's had
one too many white claws the whole
scenario is too much for Anita to handle
so she attempts to call for help but
Jennifer quickly pins her against the
wall she then prepares to bite and eat
his neck but something takes over her
and she suddenly runs away from there
the following morning at school Anita
appears Disturbed unable to shake off
the events of the previous night she
also worries about her best friend but
much to her surprise Jennifer appears in
a completely fine State and dismisses
Anita's concerns shortly after their
Professor offers condolences for those
who lost their lives in the bar incident
from the previous night everyone is
saddened by the news but Jennifer
remains indifferent and even mocks the
situation confused Anita wonders what is
wrong with her best friend she knows
that her behavior has something to do
with the Low Shoulder band later Anita
seeks out chip and tells him everything
about Jennifer including her evil
appearance from the other day sounds
like she just had one too many white
claws babe on the other hand Jennifer
approaches the college football team
captain Jonas who's grieving the loss of
his best friend apparently he also died
in the fire incident with words of
comfort Jennifer leads him to the forest
located behind their college once there
she begins to seduce him and she does a
really good job and at the same time
several birds and animals mysteriously
he starts surrounding them just as Jonas
is about to inquire further Jennifer
transforms into her evil form and
brutally disembowels him to death his
chilling screams are heard by a college
professor who rushes to the scene and
finds his mutilated corpse this is
exactly what I would look like after
Megan Fox had her way with me later in
the evening Anita and Jennifer engage in
a phone conversation Anita remains
haunted by the incident but Jennifer
urges her to move on emphasizing that
life is too short for these things in
the midst of their conversation Jennifer
deliberately Burns her own tongue with a
lighter yet she remains unharmed just
then Anita is called by her boyfriend
who shockingly informs her about Jonas's
murder making her even more worried
meanwhile Low Shoulder gains a lot of
popularity due to the false rumors that
they saved a bunch of people during that
fire hundreds and thousands of people
start requesting them for a concert and
a charity appearance at the local school
is finally confirmed not bad for a band
that named themselves after a move that
Machop that's at level 7 following this
the movie cuts to one month later the
locals including Anita are finally able
to smile again and move on from the
tragic incident however Jennifer appears
lethargic weary and unwell one day after
class she and Anita are walking down the
hallway when a classmate named Colin
asks her out on a date surprisingly
Jennifer accepts the invitation and
texts him her address inviting him to
her place but he's about to get sucked
dry later that night Colin eagerly
drives to the location provided by
Jennifer while Anita and Chip spend
intimate time together upon arriving at
the destination Colin realizes that the
area is deserted and the house is still
under construction it's sketchy but this
is the Arbiter of MGK's seed we're
talking about so he enters the house
anyway and encounters Jennifer who
momentarily startles him from behind
without wasting any time she begins to
seduce and kiss him for the first few
minutes everything goes as normal and
the poor boy has a wonderful time but
then he notices a distant Urban change
in Jennifer's eye Colin tries to run
away from there but the evil girl once
again transforms into her monstrous self
and mercilessly kills him she even
drinks his blood in a sadistic manner I
guess she's getting married to him
meanwhile Anita who is in the middle of
romance suddenly starts hallucinating
she sees Jonas's Spirit on the couch and
blood dripping from the ceiling this
unsettling experience terrifies her
leading her to abruptly leave Chip's
place and drive away however it is not
the end of her worries as she almost
runs over Jennifer who is drenched in
blood filled with panic Anita rushes
back home and locks herself in her
bedroom attempting to calm her Disturbed
mind she lies down in bed however to her
dismay she finds Jennifer present in her
room appearing normal once again this
perplexes Anita leaving her unsure of
what is happening and before she can
even react Jennifer unexpectedly kisses
her on the lips intending to help her
relax oh man following these events
Jennifer reveals a shocking truth Low
Shoulder the band from the bar fire
incident had taken her to the same
mysterious waterfall and offered her as
a virgin sacrifice to Satan in exchange
for their Fame and Fortune she further
claims that despite the success of the
sacrifice she did not die because she
was not truly a virgin this mishap also
ensured that the band stayed crap
however Jennifer explains that she never
became normal because she was
permanently possessed by Satan after the
incident she remembers waking up
unharmed even after being stabbed by the
band members several times Jennifer then
reveals that as she made her way back
home she felt extremely hungry so she
devoured her first victim a foreign
exchange student who is believed to have
died in the fire after explaining all
this Jennifer mentions something even
more shocking on that fateful night she
planned to eat Anita as well but at the
last second she had a change of heart
and she still had feelings for her best
friend Jennifer goes on to explain that
feeding she exerts extra strength and
can endure virtually any injury without
experiencing pain to demonstrate this
she deliberately cuts her hand and makes
a large wound but it heals itself in
just a matter of seconds overwhelmed by
the horrifying Revelations Anita asks
Jennifer to leave the latter complies
and jumps from the second floor window
which is about 13 feet off the ground in
the next scene Anita begins to conduct
paranormal research so that she can
learn more about the unsettling events
as of late for this she goes into the
cult section of her College library and
starts reading books about occult and
virgin sacrifices to Satan's after a lot
of research she finally learns that her
best friend is actually a succubus we
already knew that a supernatural being
that feeds on flesh these beings can
only be killed when they are hungry and
weak following this Anita shares her
findings with her boyfriend chiap hoping
for understanding and support
unfortunately he dismisses her claims
and suggests that she may need mental
assistance as the two continue chatting
a son and realization hits Anita
prompting her to break up with her
boyfriend the reason is simple she knows
that being close to him can potentially
endanger his life also he's a douchebag
that's not all Anita even forbids him
from attending the upcoming college
program however chip angrily disregards
her warnings and walks away on the day
of the college program Anita anxiously
awaits Jennifer's arrival determined to
keep a watchful eye on her meanwhile
Jennifer intercepts chip who is on his
way to attend the program she cunningly
makes up a story saying that anito is
having an affair with Colin after this
she leads him to an abandoned pool using
the same seductive tactics she had used
to kill her previous victims they're
super effective on chip back at the
program Anita grows increasingly
concerned when Jennifer does not arrive
for a long while when she can't take it
any longer she rushes to Chip's house to
check on him but learns that he has
already departed for the program worried
that something bad has happened Anita
starts looking around the area and
eventually reaches the abandoned pool
where she sees Jennifer eat her
boyfriend alive hot alarmed Anita jumps
into the pool without thinking twice and
starts battling her best friend she uses
pepper spray on Jennifer but this only
angers the latter Jennifer with
vengeance in her eyes closes in on Anita
preparing to land the final blow but a
wounded ship summons the last of his
strengths and impales Jennifer with a
pool skimmer this causes her to lose a
lot of blood making her weak she then
Retreats from the scene realizing that
she is vulnerable now following this
Anita rushes to her beloved ship and
cradles him in her arms the two have a
heart-touching conversation before he
closes his eyes and passes away Anita
who is now heartbroken and filled with
rage prepares herself for a path of
Vengeance in the middle of the night she
breaks into Jennifer's bedroom through a
window and starts attacking her a fierce
fight ensues between the two but
Jennifer gains the upper hand by sinking
her teeth into Anita's shoulder her Low
Shoulder despite this our protagonist
doesn't stop and she keeps on fighting
with all she has got at one point she
manages to rep a BFF necklace from
Jennifer's neck prompting her to
momentarily stop fighting taking full
advantage of this opportunity Anita
plunges a utility knife into Jennifer's
heart finally killing her once and for
all moments later when Jennifer's mom
arrives at the room she is horrified to
discover Anita atop her lifeless
daughter's body this is the reason why
Anita ended up in the mental Asylum it
is also revealed that she has inherited
some of Jennifer's Supernatural Powers
because of the bite on her shoulder in
the final scene Anita uses her satanic
abilities and escapes the mental
facility she then hitchhikes a ride
claiming she is following a band in the
credit scene home videos and crime scene
photos reveal that Anita has exacted
Revenge by murdering all of the members
of Low Shoulder in their hotel room as
if those idiots could afford a hotel
room
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching